i have one question from brittany
worship um uh and i'm gonna let you feel
this one
okay she says uh what is your advice for
building a trusting team
of teachers and administrators who can
navigate birth
so that they can navigate both uh the
uncertain and complex waters that lie
ahead this school year
okay great question thank you brittany
the um first first step is to understand
that trust
uh comes from behavior we we trust each
other because we behave in a way that
allows us to make that decision so
things like listening care empathy those
will immediately
generate trust when we talk about
specific teams so in this case teachers
and administrators
are they how do they build a trusting
team increasing the unknown future yeah
step one what are the attributes we're
looking for okay
so it's not just skill anymore what are
the attributes we're looking for
for this team because every team the
attributes that we need for a seal team
is different
are different from the attribute list
that we need for a team of teachers
administrators what are those attributes
and then begin to assess
each other as to whether or not you have
those attributes this time of stress and
challenge
probably has assessed some of those
things we've already seen i'm sure
brittany you've already seen
who are the patients one patient ones
who are the adaptable ones who are the
ones with empathy
who are the ones with less empathy
things like that so
so understand the attributes you're
looking for and then
start to look and assess for those as
well
a a trusted team is a mesh of people
with skills and attributes that
complement
each other and so one thing trust
requires is vulnerability vulnerability
does not just mean
showing your weakness it means also
showing your strengths because i need to
know
if simon and i are working together i
need to know exactly what he's good at
when he's not good at he needs to know
what i'm good at and what i'm not good
at so i know when to lean on him
and he knows when to lean on me that's
what a trusted team does
so so look at that uh and and start to
think about that uh in terms of your
team that's great
[Music]
you